john is a great sport have to be anger
in the dark to be considered a great
piece of art not at all I think that
that is a one of the great
misconceptions that in order to reach
the level of greatness it has to be very
dark or have a very down ending or
fatalistic ending and so on I think this
is has never been true certainly in
popular storytelling were much more
likely to have the happy ending but the
what is much more important is does the
story play out the way it should within
its own parameters is it telling the
story of the right way and if that means
a happy ending because of what has
happened leading up to that ending then
that's what it should be if it's a dark
ending but it's justified that the in
the way that the story was written
leading up to it how the character was
created the weakness of the character
had at the beginning if that leads to a
you know a fatal ending then that's the
way that story has to be done always
tell Reuters you can definitely have a
popular script with a with an unhappy
ending if the character earned it if the
character earns it then even though it
doesn't end up you know happy that the
person that the character was not
successful it is right for that
particular character and that's much
more important for the audience to have
the internal logic work does that still
apply to television song in television
again we go back to that fundamental
distinction between the standalone show
and the serial show the standalone show
is almost always going to have that
happy ending on occasion we will get a
detective story where the criminal gets
off
and we have this tragic ending but that
happens very rarely because part of the
reason that the audience comes to a
standalone show is the solution they
want that sense of accomplishment that
they get and they know they're going to
get every week when you go into a serial
you much more likely to have not
necessarily get a negative ending
because in a serial that's part of the
point is there is no real ending so and
because you have many more characters in
a serial than you have in a standalone
show some of your characters will be on
and up and others will be on the down
and there it's much more likely that you
will have down endings for example at
the end of a season as opposed to in a
particular episode because when we're
talking about a season we're dealing in
major arcs and one of the things that
you do as the showrunner and as the
staff writers is right at the very
beginning of the season when you chart
it out on the board which characters are
going to end up with an up art and what
you're going to end with a Down arc and
you want to figure that out and
interweave that over the course of the
entire season
you